In the Philippines you can be charged with
the crime of "unjust vexation" for doing just
that, vexing someone.
In the Arctic Town of Longyearbyen, dying
is against the law.
This is because bodies don't decompose in
the permafrost.
So if you fall terminally ill you will hastily
be despatched by plane to the Norwegian mainland,
where you can die without being arrested.
In Mobile, Alabama, it is against the law
to throw confetti or spray silly string.
In Saudi Arabia, it's illegal for any woman
to drive a car or vote in the general election.
Although this is due to be changed in 2015.
In Singapore chewing gum is illegal.
If you get caught "dealing" chewing gum you
can get fined up to $2,000.
There is a law in South Carolina called the
no "mock proposal" law, which states that
anybody above the age of 16 is not allowed
to perform a proposal if they don't really
mean it.
In Montana, "proxy weddings" are allowed for
those serving in the military, which means
a friend can pretend to be the groom or the
bride and the marriage will still be considered
valid.
In some cases both the bride and the groom
are absent.
In Arkansas there still exists a law from
the 1800s that states a husband is allowed
to beat his wife, but only once a month.
The UK has its fair share of highly unusual
laws, In Britain it is illegal to handle a
salmon in suspicious circumstances.
Also, in Britain, it is illegal to import
potatoes into England or Wales if you have
reasonable cause to believe that they are
Polish.
In Britain it is illegal to operate a cow
while intoxicated.
In York, England, it is perfectly legal to
shoot a Scotsman with a bow and arrow.
On any day except Sundays.
In England it is actually illegal to be drunk
in a pub.
In Liverpool, England, it is illegal for a
woman to be topless except as a clerk in a
tropical fish store.
In parts of India, a man who is in debt can
offer up his wife as collateral until the
debt is paid.
In Hong Kong, there's a law that allows a
wife to kill her husband if she finds him
cheating.
However, she must kill him with her bare hands.
In Samoa it is illegal to forget your wife's
birthday.
In France, it is illegal to name a pig Napoleon.
In Russia, Vladimir Putin just recently made
it illegal to tell kids that gay people exist.
In La Crosse, Wisconsin it is illegal to "worry
a squirrel".
In Alabama it is illegal to wear a fake moustache
that causes laughter in church.
In Pacific Grove, California, "molesting"
butterflies can result in a $500 fine.
In Florida it's against the law to dream about
another man's wife or cow.
In Minnesota it's illegal to sleep naked.
And finally, in Virginia and Wyoming it's
illegal to tickle women.